el 2 de febrero del 2010 la tesorería de
los eeuu estimó que su deuda nacional
tenía un valor de 1.2 278 por 10 a la 13
dólares ok eso es una número inmenso
para que te des una idea 1 por 10 a las
6 es un millón entonces esto de aquí es
12 veces más grande que un millón de
millones de millones así es que este
número es muy grande pero bueno un censo
de ese mismo año estima que había
3.0 86 por 10 a la 8 ciudadanos eso es
muy parecido a 31 mil millones
aquí hay 31 mil millones de ciudadanos
estadounidenses
ahora usando estas estimaciones calcula
la deuda nacional por persona ok en esta
oración
toda esta oración lo que nos dice es
toma la deuda de toda la nación y divide
la por persona y entonces nos pregunten
a cada una de las 31 mil millones de
ciudadanos estadounidenses que parte de
esta deuda nacional le toca aunque hay
pero también nos dicen que para hacer
los cálculos usemos notación científica
y que redondeamos al cuarto lugar
decimal y finalmente nos dicen que
expresemos el resultado en ambas
notaciones la anotación de cimet que es
la que usamos normalmente y la notación
científica que es este tipo de notación
entonces queremos calcular la deuda por
persona así es que lo que vamos a hacer
es tomar la deuda y dividirla entre la
cantidad de personas que hay la deuda es
1.227 8 x 10 a la 13
y la cantidad de personas es
3.086 por 10 a la 8 y lo que vamos a
hacer es separar esta multiplicación y
división en dos pedazos este es el
primer pedazo
esto es igual a
1.227 8 entre
3.086 por
este otro pedazo
10 a la 13 entre 10 a la 8 aunque esto
es lo más fácil entonces vamos a
resolverlo primero tenemos aquí 10 a la
13 entre 10 a la 8 y a mí lo que se me
hace más fácil es pensar esto como
10 a la 13 x 10 al menos ocho cierto
porque justo este menos en el exponente
significa 1 entre y aquí tenemos 10 a la
8 y bueno ya que tenemos esto escrito de
esta forma podemos ver que tenemos
exactamente la misma base que es 10 y
entonces a la hora de multiplicar lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sumar los
exponentes y nos queda 10 al 13 menos 8
5 gray el atajo para no tener que
escribir esto es pensar que es lo único
que tenemos que hacer es al exponente de
arriba restarle el exponente de abajo
entonces esto de aquí es igual a 10 a la
ahora para resolver esta división vamos
a usar la calculadora
tenemos que dividir
1.2
278 entre
3.0 86 y lo que nos queda es
0.3 97 y queremos redondear al cuarto
lugar de zimmer y 6 es mayor que 5
entonces este 8 se convierte en un 9
recuérdenlo muy bien punto 3 979
punto 3
90 punto 3 979 para que se vea más
bonito por 10 a las 5 gray este es la
deuda nacional por persona pero hay que
tomar en cuenta que todavía no lo
escribimos como notación científica ok
para que sea notación científica este
número de aquí tiene que ser mayor o
igual a 1 y definitivamente no es mayor
o igual a 1 pero lo podemos arreglar muy
fácilmente aunque lo que podemos hacer
es digamos multiplicar a este número por
10 y dividir a este número entre 10
aunque bueno eso suena muy complicado
entonces pero hay una forma muy fácil de
escribirlo aunque tenemos por aquí
0.3
y se está multiplicando por 10 y por 10
a la 4
ok y entonces todo esto de aquí se
convierte en
3.979 cierto claro que no se nos tiene
que olvidar este por 10 a la 4 por 10 a
la 4 podríamos decir que este 10 a las 5
le presta un 10 a este número para que
fuera mayor o igual que uno y eso sí
tiene sentido no porque 10 a las 5 si es
exactamente igual a 10 por 10 a la 4 y
bueno ahora si lo bueno es que este
número ya está escrito en forma de
notación científica entonces esto ya es
la deuda nacional por persona escrita en
notación científica pero nos piden que
también le escribamos connotación
decimal porque entonces tenemos que
convertir esta anotación de zimmer
recuerda que la anotación decimales la
que usemos no se todos los días
si es que pues vamos a desarrollar esta
multiplicación tenemos por aquí
3.979 y estamos multiplicando por 10 a
la 4 aunque entonces lo más fácil es
simplemente mover el punto decimal si
tenemos este número y lo multiplicamos
por 10 lo que nos queda es el punto
decimal por acá
osea
39.79 ahora si multiplicamos este número
por 10 al cuadrado entonces el decimal
se mueve en dos lugares y nos queda el
punto decimal por acá o sea 300
97.9 si multiplicamos por 10 a la 3
el punto decimal queda por acá 3 mil 979
dólares por persona pero tenemos que
multiplicar por 10 a la 4 así es que el
punto decimal tiene que quedar por acá
por lo que tenemos que agregar un 0 por
aquí ok entonces la deuda nacional por
persona es igual
es
97 90
39 mil
790 dólares por persona eso significa
que en eeuu cada hombre mujer bebé o
niño o adolescente
debe 39 mil 790 dólares